DEMOCRATS DEFINED A VICTIM HOOD
DOWN, THAT'S THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
EVERYWHERE YOU TURN, THE
DEMOCRATS AND THEIR FAWNING
MEDIA ENABLERS ARE ELEVATING
CONCERN OF NON-AMERICANS OVER
ACTUAL AMERICANS.
I INTERVIEWED THE PARENTS OF
15-YEAR-OLD NYSSA MACON WHO WAS
MURDERED BY GANG MEMBERS.
THEY WERE PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
GUEST AT THE STATE OF THE UNION.
I ASKED THEM WHAT THEY THOUGHT
OF THE DEMOCRATS FAILURE TO
STAND WHEN THEY WERE RECOGNIZED.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
DISRESPECTFUL FOR THE SIMPLE
FACT THAT THEY WERE THERE, THEY
WERE AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
IF THEY NOT HAVE THE RESPECT OR
TO HONOR WHAT JUST HAPPENED TO
OUR LIVES AND TO AMERICA'S
LIVES, REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU
FEEL ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, SHOW
THE RESPECT.
I WOULD'VE SHOWN RESPECT IF THAT
WAS THEIR LOVED ONE.
>> Laura: SO CLASSY AND SO
MOVING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RAISED TO
ADDRESS THE BRUTALITY,
VICTIMIZING LAW-ABIDING INNOCENT
AMERICA, HE ALSO HIGHLIGHTED
FORGOTTEN VICTIMS.
ALL LIBERAL MEDIA TYPES COULD DO
IN RESPONSE TO ALL OF THIS WAS
TO DISMISS IT AS MS-13?
THAT THREAT IS OVERBLOWN, ITS
POLITICAL HEIGHT.
HER MOM REACTED TO THAT
SENTIMENT WITH INCREDULITY.
>> I HAVE NO WORDS.
THESE ARE GANG MEMBERS THAT JUST
DECIDED TO BE A JUDGE IN A JURY
TO TAKE MY DAUGHTER OUT LIKE
THAT.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
I DON'T WANT TO HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY ELSE'S FAMILY.
FOR MOST DEMOCRATS, THESE
VICTIMS AND THEIR FAMILIES, THEY
ARE ALMOST INVISIBLE.
THE ANGUISH OF THOSE FAMILIES IS
INCONVENIENT TO THE STORY LINE
AMNESTY, BENEFITS, CARE,
COMPASSION, ET CETERA.
LIBERALS EMPATHY ONLY SEEMS TO
GO ONE WAY.
>> THE AWFUL PICTURES OF
DREAMERS BEING DEPORTED I THINK
WILL RALLY THE NATION.
>> FOR ME THE FIRST STEP BEGINS
IF IT IS A PRIORITY THAT'S TOO
LONG HAS BEEN PUSHED TO THE BACK
BURNER.
>> WE HAVE HEARD MORE INSULTING
WORDS OF IGNORANCE AND PREJUDICE
TOWARD IMMIGRANT FAMILIES LAST
NIGHT.
>> Laura: THOSE AMERICAN
FAMILIES ARE PATRIOTIC AT ALL.
RAISE YOUR HAND IF YOU ARE WARY
OF THE ENDLESS IMMIGRATION SABA
STORY STARTED OUT BY MEDIA COAST
TO COAST.
>> A CROWD OF RABBIS PREACHED,
ON THE OUTSIDE, YOU WOULDN'T
KNOW THIS MAY BE THE LAST TIME.
NOT SURE HOW IT'S GOING TO END.
>> BACK IN 1998, HE WAS DEPORTED
AND THE NEXT YEAR HE CAME BACK
ILLEGALLY TO FIND WORK.
SIX AMERICAN-BORN CHILDREN AND A
SEVENTH ON THE WAY.
>> Laura: YOU HEARD THAT.
HE WAS HERE 20 YEARS, DOES NOT
SPEAK ENGLISH.
HE WAS DEPORTED ONCE ONLY TO
COME BACK ILLEGALLY.
AND HIS 13-YEAR-OLD WIFE IS A
DACA RECIPIENT.
CONTRARY TO WHAT DEMOCRATS HAVE
TRIED TO DO TO BRAINWASH
GENERATIONS OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS
TO BELIEVE THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, TERRIBLE HEART WAS
PEOPLE, THEY'VE DONE THE SAME
WITH HISPANICS.
IT'S ONLY DONALD TRUMP WHO HAD
THE GUTS TO POINT OUT THAT AN
UNENFORCED BORDER HITS BLACK,
HISPANIC, AND WORKING POOR
GENERALLY DISPROPORTIONATELY
HARD.
LOWERING WAGES, SHUTTERING A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT OF ENTIRE JOB
SECTORS AND OF COURSE, THE CRIME
SECTORS AND OF COURSE, THE CRIM
CRIME.
PLAYING THE CRASS GAME OF
IDENTITY POLITICS, WHAT
DEMOCRATS DO IS THEY CREATED
THEIR OWN CLASSES OF IMAGINARY
VICTIMS.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS ANXIETY ABOUT
DEPORTATION EDGE AS YOU JUST SAW
IN THAT PIECE IS COVERED
ENDLESSLY AND WITH MAXIMUM
EMOTION.
LOTS OF SYMPATHETIC NODS FROM
REPORTERS.
POLITICIANS STAND AND APPLAUD
FOR SO-CALLED DREAMERS DEMANDING
RIGHTS.
IF YOU DISAGREE AND YOU BELIEVE
IN IMMIGRATION MEASURES THAT ARE
DESIGNED TO BENEFIT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, YOU ARE SMEARED.
>> YOU HAVE A VERY HOSTILE
ANTI-IMMIGRANT VOICES IN THE
HOUSE.
>> LAST WEEK THEY MADE ANOTHER
SHAMEFUL ANTI-IMMIGRANT DECISION
BY ENDING TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS FOR 31,000 SALVADORANS.
>> REPUBLICAN SENATE, HOUSE, ALL
THREE OF THE MOST
ANTI-IMMIGRATION THAT THERE IS.
>> Laura: THAT'S COMPLETELY
ABSURD.
I'M GOING TO THROW IT RIGHT BACK
IN HIS FACE.
OUR DEMOCRATS ANTI-CHILDREN WHEN
THEY FAIL TO STAND UP FOR
VICTIMS SUCH AS THE 7-YEAR-OLD
INDIANA GIRL WHO WAS REPEATEDLY
THIS MONTH BY A 24-YEAR-OLD
ILLEGAL ALIEN?
WE HAVE A PICTURE OF HIM.
WAS THIS ANIMAL A DREAMER,
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
THEY DO COMPRISE 22% OF OUR
FEDERAL PRISON POPULATION, THAT
IS A FACT.
A NEW STUDY OF ARIZONA RESIDENTS
CONVICTED FOR A CRIME THAN OTHER
ARIZONANS.
THAT IS OBSCENE.
WE HAVE A THING CALLED A CATCH
AND RELEASE POLICY, IT'S
COMPLETELY NUTS UNDER WHICH
I.C.E. AGENTS MUST RELEASE
UNACCOMPANIED AND ACCOMPANIED
ALIEN CHILDREN BACK INTO THE
COUNTRY, THEY ARE CAUGHT AT THE
BORDER AND RELEASED BACK INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
THEN RECITALS THESE KIDS IN
COMMUNITIES AND IN STATES LIKE
YOURS.
WE HAVE RELEASED 100,000 OF
THESE UNACCOMPANIED MINORS INTO
THE UNITED STATES JUST SINCE
FISCAL YEAR 2016, UNBELIEVABLE.
A RECENT HHS STUDY SHOWS THAT
THE MAJORITY OF UNACCOMPANIED
ILLEGAL ALIEN MINORS ARE 15-17
YEARS OLD.
THEY ARE MALES, NORTHERN
VIRGINIA GANG TASK FORCE A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO,
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO HIS CREDIT
AND OUR BENEFIT WANTS TO END
THIS SCOURGE.
>> President Trump: MANY OF
THESE GANG MEMBERS TOOK
ADVANTAGE OF OUR GLARING
LOOPHOLES IN OUR LAWS TO ENTER
THE COUNTRY AS ILLEGAL
TONIGHT I AM CALLING ON CONGRESS
TO FINALLY CLOSE THE DEADLY
LOOPHOLES THAT HAVE ALLOWED
MS-13 ANOTHER CRIMINAL GANG TO
BREAK INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> Laura: THE CONGRESSIONAL
BLACK CAUCUS AND ALL OF
DEMOCRATS WHO SET FUMING RATHER
THAN STAND AND SUPPORT OF
GRIEVING AMERICAN FAMILIES, I
SAY SHAME ON YOU.